monday marks the conclusion of operation
broken fang now that cs go fans were
expecting
what they were not expecting was that
finally
after eons of clamoring valve listened
to the community and made a change to
the
active duty map pool putting
ancient oh okay
well i mean it's not anubis but you know
that's
that's fine the point is that they
finally took out
[Music]
wait that's not mirage
okay so you know the drill like the
video subscribe to the channel
and please make sure to turn on
notifications so that when valve does
inevitably take mirage out of the map
pool
and i make a video peace signing beside
its grave
you get to catch it as soon as it goes
live okay so let's dive
straight into it broken fang is over
valve pushed a
small update as a result and there's a
lot of stuff to talk about
first off the case
it's fine as expected the broken fang
set of gloves
is now available outside of the
operation so i can keep trying my luck
for those tiger strike specialists
and blood clot motos in terms of the
skins themselves
i don't like to openly criticize
cosmetics because the workshop artists
actually work
really hard on making them and literally
make a living based on their success
so i'll refrain from talking about the
ones i don't like
it just always makes me feel bad what i
will say is that the low ends are
actually some of the most exciting we've
seen in a long time
the clear polymer glock is extremely
clean
the slate ak is actually goaded in terms
of crafts
and i have been waiting ages for that
button masher mac 10.
valve also decided to take their newly
introduced
statistics hub to its logical conclusion
and turn it into a monthly subscription
type deal
it's called cs go 360 stats and for 99
cents a month american
you can get access to match stats from
the competitive premier and wingman game
modes as well as the round win chance
report that was first included in broken
fang
it's pretty much a paid version of
leedify that in all probability
isn't as good that said it's valve
published and
very cheap so all in all a harmless
thing to at least
try out for a dollar a month and if it's
anything like dota plus
it'll receive constant updates the care
and attention of the developers for
years to come
and will totally end up being a
worthwhile investment
i can't do it i just can't now onto the
thing you've all been waiting for
the [ __ ] that matters the chickens
they got a visual upgrade that's uh
that's about it it's great though look
at that [ __ ]
look how clean that [ __ ] is this
man is an
absolute unit dude's just strutting
around like he owns the place
what a little gangster but the thing
that really sent the community for a
loop wasn't the changes to the poultry
it was them adding ancient to the active
duty
map pool now for those who don't know cs
go is kind of a
singularity when it comes to map
infrastructure the majority of the
game's most iconic and competitive
battlegrounds are nearly
20 years old and people have become
extremely accustomed to playing on them
it's for that reason that the community
tends to spend years
begging people to ideate create and
implement
novel play places so as not to die of
boredom
only to [ __ ] all over everything as soon
as there's even the remote
chance that they'll ever make it into
the competitive map pool
suffice it to say both valve and the
community have developed a sort of
weird unhealthy relationship with
injecting new life into the cs go map
pool
insofar as it never happens well
it does it just occurs at a glacial pace
you know how in lord of the rings it
takes the ants like a billion years to
say anything in their native tongue
that's kind of what it's like when valve
has to decide whether or not they're
going to make a change to the active
duty mapple
i am told the other cs go devs that dust
to might be getting hopelessly stale
we're going to invert the b site doors
well that's good news anyway as for this
change in particular
it's kind of a weird one why well for
starters
because of the map they opted to take
out instead of saying sia to dust2
which everyone seems to hate mirage
which is
objectively the oldest and most solved
map of the entire bunch
or what is undeniably the worst most
one-dimensional [ __ ] show in the whole
of counter-strike
inferno i mean uh vertigo
they said peace to train which despite
being extremely ct
sided is one of the most intricate and
entertaining maps in
all of cs look whatever your feelings on
train may or may not be
i think we can all agree that it didn't
need to go
over oh i don't know mirage
the only upside is that now liquid who
notoriously man train every chance they
get
can finally start winning again but like
please guys right right where things get
really interesting though is with
respect to the map
they replaced it with aztec i mean
ancient ancient is a valve-created aztec
inspired bomb defusal map that was first
introduced in operation broken fang
a little over six months ago it's big
beautiful
and well very green so why is it
surprising that valve chose to include
it well
in a sense it isn't because they made it
in another sense
it is because there are other
community-sourced maps
such as anubis that have been
play-tested for much longer and felt a
tad bit closer to being competitively
viable
that's not to say there's anything
overtly wrong with ancient
in fact a lot of pros seem to be taking
a liking to it but it definitely is in
need of a little bit of tweaking
both in terms of layout which is fine
that's the case with every map
and in terms of optimization remember
when cache got reworked and started
causing all those fps issues
kind of the same thing with ancient
turns out being big beautiful and green
isn't always a good thing don't believe
me just ask a liege
i do think that valve needs to work on
the fps optimization of the map
my computer's top of the line and still
having a lot of fps drops and getting
under 200 150
and if that's my case i think that's
going to be hard for a lot of people so
i think they really need to work on that
there's also the issue of bugs to
consider but rest assured
as soon as the announcement went live
the best cs go players
in the world turned all their attention
to unearthing every problem with ancient
imaginable
which of course is exactly what valve
wanted
because as it turns out the best way to
turn a good map
into a great one is to shove it into the
active duty map pool first
and ask questions later needless to say
if you want your game's
savviest competitors to give a rat's ass
about your map
you should probably stake their
livelihoods on it that may sound
mean or rash or unreasonable but i
assure you
it is not counter-strike needs to stay
fresh if it's going to stay
relevant for the long haul and in order
to do that
it needs new maps or better yet it needs
people to care about the existing maps
that are just waiting for a shot at
being competitively viable
the ones that countless creators are
putting countless hours into
only to have people play it one time and
go
oh this isn't as perfect as the other
maps that have existed for longer than
most of the player base has been alive
guess i'm going back to dust too take
overpass for instance introduced in 2013
as part of operation bravo overpass has
spent
eight years being transformed from a
literal dumpster fire
into what is quite possibly the single
greatest map
in the history of cs go so before you
start [ __ ] all over ancient
take a second to think about what this
spells for the future of counter-strike
a new map that wasn't a remake just took
the spot of a
20 year old masterpiece now is that a
sad thing
i love train and even i can admit of
course not
it's the start of something new these
may not be the maps you wanted to see
juggled
hell they weren't the maps that i wanted
to see juggled but that doesn't matter
the point is that they were juggled
that's what counter-strike needs more of
that is what is going to keep
counter-strike fresh
for generations to come
valve also decided to take their newly
introduced statistics hub and take it to
its logical can
i just repeat it take twice two it's
jesus valve also opted to take their
statistics hub to it
i'm gonna shoot myself on this line i
was doing so well dude and i'm whiffing
shots on this easy
frag why you can't win every round can't
win all of them devin you know
sometimes you know even simple whiffs
are shot here and there
not saying that i'm simple devin i'm
saying that simple and i have never been
seen in the same room together